so my name is Jeff you boys I'm actually
here wearing two hats I work with Peter
at intelligent television and with nan
Rubin at channel 13 where we're working
on an ended project to preserve digital
Public Television so this panel is going
to go kind of from the general to the
specific i have a few fairly general
observations and examples that I wanted
to show and then we'll go into more
detail about what's going on at channel
13 so I want to talk about collaborative
approaches to moving image archiving and
the video archiving if you look up the
definition of what our archive a is
online you end up with two two clusters
of things and one is it's a place where
historical documents are stored in an
institution that's designed to last a
long time the other is it's a collection
of UNIX files and I think that that's
sort of where we are in in the archiving
world where we're at this place where
the definitions of what we're doing or
changing and shifting the definition of
what a what television is is also
changing televisions in transition and
is being redefined so the way it's being
distributed is moving from rf2 I key the
way it's being stored as moving from
tape to disc the way people are watching
this moving from scheduled to
unscheduled and from the tube in the
living room to the big screen or such a
small screen there are various other
formatting changes that are happening
from Mt schd from local to global and
from a broadcast mode to something
that's more interactive more like a
conversation what's also happening as
televisions getting a memory feeling
very retro today this is the first tape
machine from 1956 it's a two inch
machine made by impacts and as telling
because a memory we're seeing that
happen in lots of different places
ranging from projects like the American
archive that nan will talk about to a
popular form like YouTube which ov has
been working on to a lot of smaller
efforts that are diverse and distributed
the university of delaware now has a
project with 10 valve
local news clips that are up online for
viewing and if you click a license you
can search through them and find them
the Norman Lear Center in the Midwest
has a collection of local news Scola has
been recording 80 channels from around
the world 24 hours a day this is mainly
for language education the television
archive in Bowie Maryland has been
recording for the last seven years
material off air Vanderbilt as many
people know has been going since
nineteen sixty eight so there's a lot of
projects that are kind of moving in
parallel there is now an opportunity for
them to begin to work together but it's
not really clear what we're talking
about in a sense are we talking about
something that's corporate property
that's being either appropriated or
preserved are we talking about an
experience that people can share with
friends or are we talking about public
memory and things are used in public
dialogue and the answer to that question
really it kind of depends on who you ask
before people have different opinions
about this I tried to find some books
that were you know a counterpoint to
free culture and I couldn't really find
too many books but I didn't find the FBI
warning which we've all had seared on
our retinas and archives are right in
the middle of this conflict over what is
what is public and what is private and
you know the one side I think to go to
extremes you see the proposal of life
imprisonment for copyright violations
under the new law of a number of birds a
copyright violation for thinking about
copyright violations bought prize here
so so archives are right in the middle
of this of this conflict and it's almost
like a collision of two different
systems of belief it's it's difficult to
argue at the belief system last weekend
the new york times ran an editorial by
michael health room arguing that there
was no difference between tangible and
intangible property and you know it's a
really crew distinction to talk about
market and gift economy that's a fairly
crude split of the kinds of transactions
we engage in but it may be one that's
that's useful it kind of matched to
Stewart Brand same as comment he said
that information wants to be free and
that's the part that usually gets quoted
but the second half of the sentences
information also wants to be expensive
and so we're seeing a collision of these
two approaches to the collection and
sharing of our of our common cultural
materials at least that's what i think
of the most this is the FBI warning that
has been rewritten it was in the
presentation that Peter gave and it
emphasizes that we all have fair use as
an option that's available to us and I
personally would like to see that as a
more of a ethos in in the in the world
but it's not up to me if you talk to
people that are in social science one of
the things that they'll tell you is that
networks the kind of networks that were
on now lower the cost of collective
action to quote another friend of mine
never underestimate how much free time
people have on the Internet two examples
of that one was Partridge 47 this was
the Hillary Clinton remix of the Apple
advertisement from 1984 a lot of people
spent a lot of time finding the person
who actually made this ad in the end of
it in the end it turned out it was
somebody that was working for a
contractor for the Obama campaign and
that person was fired a second example
of this fanatical devotion to Providence
once a clip becomes widely seen is
lonely girl 15 that was a case of
something was kind of a asked almost
like an astroturf campaign or fake
authenticity of an emotional experience
that a young girl was having as
supposedly the daughter of Christian
fundamentalist parents only it was bogus
only it was vocally so we're seeing
online communities and archives that are
built around this common production and
collection and cataloging I want to give
some examples of that the first one is
kind of a lesson to how much you can
control information it turns out there's
a community of people that really like
to hang around airports and the thing
that they like to do at airports is they
like to note which planes are taking off
and which ones are landing and what the
tail numbers of these
planes are and they began noticing some
strange patterns of behavior at airports
around the world and sharing this on
message boards and they trace this plane
tail number to a front company in North
Carolina which turned out to be a front
company for the CIA and it turned out
that it's this plane was being used for
extraordinary rendition this was how the
network of secret prisons that's being
run around the world was exposed and so
here was an organization that for 60
years has perfected techniques of
controlling the information that it
holds and just threw a cagar on almost
casual encounter with a large online
community that information became public
we see that with video to it was a
project a witness that's been alluded to
here before grace Lyle has spoken at
previous conferences that theater and I
have done and this is an archive of
human rights violation so it's an effort
to share video footage of human rights
violations around the world it's kind of
like the Rodney King video all the time
only only worse another example of
collective work and collective
cataloging as a project called Dowell
this is a small company in berkeley
california at this point they've gotten
metadata from more than they've gotten
agreements with more than 100 sites and
they have got index or index data
related to over 11 million videos so
this is a giant collection of commentary
and annotations and tags drawn from lots
of video hosting sites so if you think
about the difficulty of cataloging and
the problem of dealing with a medium
that's not really though it's okay to
computers this approach of throwing up
material in front of large numbers of
people who then annotate it seems like a
promising thing David rice at democracy
now
in the audience memory so David's been
running an interesting project involving
lots of volunteers who have been
cataloging and transcribing material
from democracy now do you have a quick
commenter and function of the Seldon
radio program and we have a volunteer
coordinator who collects all the data
from different volunteers and want help
the organization and like we set up a
database manager would volunteer project
so email our volunteer list which is
about 6,000 people asking would like to
help catalog audio and then our database
will match their email the FTP address
of the directory of audio that they can
work on and then they get forms and
instructions and they send that back to
intern who usually coordinates the
project to to quality control the data
and migrated into our database that's a
good way of you know letting our
audience help with a creative data we
just saw that sub another example of a
community that's been really fanatic
about careful annotation of rich media
is the Grateful Dead communities that's
up on the internet archive and it's
involved lots of people carefully poring
over shared playlists tomorrow we're
going to hear from a project called meta
did this is based at the University of
Santa Cruz it was just funded by the
sunlight foundation netted it has been
recording material off of c-span for a
little over a year and they've been
removing the copyrighted material
material that belongs to C span and
taking the material that belongs to us
material that comes off of the cameras
in the house and senate that are owned
by the public and they've begun to
annotate that video with things like
what are the campaign contributors to
someone who's speaking on the screen and
they're doing a lot of clever things
you'll hear more about it
Abrams Stern tomorrow but they're
reading the titling information they're
ocra that titling information they're
combining it with closed caption data so
that you can search through it they're
pulling data from an organization called
open secrets that has campaign
contributions and they're using all open
software that lets you point to
particular things in the closed caption
stream so you can see where someone has
set a particular quote and they're
building this with an eye towards making
it easy for people to embed particular
quotes into blogs and other media and
you can imagine lots of uses for this
you can imagine the local television
news stations that are hurting for
content being able to find something
about what their local representative
said so it's an interesting project
another example of this kind of
collaborative effort is LibriVox Libre
boxes reading works at classic
literature and you can sign up you can
read a chapter and if you want to
download something you can so these are
all examples of archivists working to
essentially tap large pools of
volunteers on the internet and that
seems like a really promising approach
to lowering some of the costs that
haven't been dropping we've seen the
cost of disk space go down by
ninety-eight percent since the Library
of Congress did its report on television
archiving in 1997 but the cost of
cataloging hasn't really started to move
the other form of collaboration that
Peter and I've been talking about and
talking about with people here and then
we'd like to hear more about from people
in the room is this idea of
public-private partnerships on the one
hand they seem like they can be a
sustainable approach to long-term access
on the other hand some of them have been
secret some of the negotiations have
been a symmetric and it seems like
there's a lot of ambivalence in the
community of librarians and archivists
about about these partnerships we don't
really know what good terms are we don't
understand how the terms in these
agreements are going to affect the
possible uses of this material at some
future time so you can imagine lots of
different applications for digital books
for example and those applications may
be
affected by the terms and conditions
that are in the agreements that are
being signed so intelligent television
and OCLC the research libraries group
division OCLC are doing a project to
look at to look at these partnerships
from the hope haves and results to
publish by the end of the summer so kind
of want to rush through this and close
with some points of discussion or things
that I'm curious about are things that I
would like to talk with people in the
room about over the course of the next
day one is the effective partnerships
and restrictions on future applications
for scan materials the second is video
CMS or interfaces to video archives it's
not clear what what those should look
like what the skin to collection of UNIX
files that will look like approaches and
costs or mass clearance and finally
approaches to collaborative cataloging
so with that I'm going to turn it over
to nan Rubin my colleague at channel 13